[音楽]
私はがん細胞をある方法で見分けることが
できる技術を開発しています
その方法が
光です
光で癌細胞を見分けられる可能性がわかっ
てきています
では
光とは具体的にどういうものでしょうか
空に浮かぶ虹を見たときあなたにはどの
くらいの色が区別できるでしょうか日本で
は二条約ときに
7色で描くことが多いと思います
アメリカでは
6色で描かれたりアフリカの一部の地域で
は
8色で描かれることもあるそうです
では
光の持つ色はどのくらいあるんでしょうか
実は
光は無限食です
赤とオレンジの間にも
無数の色が存在しています
これらは人間の目では
容易に区別できません
私たちはこれを
ゴーストカラーと呼んでいます
私たちが見えていると思っているこの世界
には見ることのできない
ゴーストカラーが存在しておりこの世界に
はまだまだ未知の世界が広がっています
ではどうすればその
ゴーストカラーを見ることができるの
でしょうか
物体は
光を反射もしくは透過しその変化した光が
人の目に入るそこで
電気信号となって
脳内にて色が認識されます
つまり
光という存在がありそれを変化させる
物質という存在があり
変化した光を捉える目は
センサであるということです
人の目には平均的に3色の色のセンサーが
あります
RGBって呼ばれる
赤と緑と青の3色の光を捉えることが
できるセンサーです
この
三原色のセンサでは
実は
ゴーストカラーを捉えることはできません
色は
無限食なのでなるべく多くの光を捉え
られるセンサーが
必要です
そのために生まれたのが分厚期です
よくある文光器は
内部にプリズムのようなものが存在し
入ってきた光を
色ごとに分解しそれぞれの光の強度を
計測することで
光の情報を取り出すことができます
運行機には1点の
ポイントの
文法情報しか得られないという欠点があり
ました
その欠点を補うために生まれたのが
ハイパースペクトルカメラです
このハイパースペクトルカメラは文字通り
カメラとして
画像のように
二次元の空間情報を得るとともに
各ピクセルごとに
文庫情報も得ることができます
これはパプリカなどを写した
普通の画像に見えるかもしれません
しかしこのようにパプリカの1点を
クリックすると141
原色の
文庫情報が得られます
通常の画像ではこれが
RGBの3つの情報しかありません
ハイパースペクトルカメラの命名者は私の
恩師である
佐取慎教寺です
佐取教授は
宇宙工学を専門とされており
現在の
JAXAである
宇宙科研究所の研究員として
隼という小学生探査機の
要エンジンの開発を主導された先生です
私はというと高校卒業後カリフォルニアの
2年生の大学に進学しまして
宇宙物理学を専攻していました
私には
ノーベル賞を受賞できるような
発明発見をしたいという夢があります
そのための生涯を捧げられるような研究
テーマを探していたのが
8年前です
かねてから
光の研究がしたいというふうに思ってい
ました
ノーベル生理学賞の受賞者でもある
ニールスフィンセンという方がいます
この方は
特定の波長の光を
患部に照射することによって
病が治るということを示したお医者さん
です
これは現在でも
光線治療と呼ばれあまり大きく取り上げ
られることはありませんが
幅広い疾患の治療に利用されています
テレビで紹介されていた
佐取教授とハイパースクトルカメラこれを
見たことで私はすぐにアメリカの大学を
辞めて日本に帰国しました
その後
佐取教授に助言をいただきながら
昼夜問わず研究を続けハイパーストラ
カメラで何が見られるのか何に使えるのか
ということを研究していました
私がこだわったのは常に
本質を捉えようと努力することです
現実のデータには
様々なノイズが含まれます
の場合は
光の当たり方1つでも大きくデータが変化
します
蛍光灯火で撮影するのかそれとも太陽効果
で撮影するのかによっても変化します
そしてハイパースペシャルカメラの内部の
センサーにもノイズ成分があります
こうした様々なノイズを取り除きいかに
その物体の特有の色情報を引っ張り出して
くるかというところについて
撮影方法から
解析のアルゴリズムまであらゆる手法を
試しては
修正をするということを繰り返す
独自のフローを作り上げました
実はそれでも十分ではありません
撮影している対象そのものについての知識
がなければ
データがどういう意味を持つのかという
ことを
真に理解することはできないと私は思い
ます
私がこれまで解析してきたのは
癌細胞です
約7年前に
佐取教授の紹介によって
北里大学の医学部の先生を紹介いただき
ました
その先生方は病理と呼ばれています
病理というのは文字通り病気の断りを
明らかにするおいしさのことです
もっと平たく説明するとがん細胞などを
顕微鏡で観察し
診断を行う先生の方々ですそこで
先生方に癌細胞を顕微鏡に取り付けられた
ハイパースペシャルカメラで
撮影をさせていただきながらこれまで約
1万例の
データを収集し解析を行いました
海洋性大腸炎から大腸がんに編成していく
感覚グレードを
病院の先生に4段階に分けていただき
個の細胞をハイパーさせているカメラで
撮影しました
これを機械学習すると
98.7%という制度が得られました
このことから
眼科していく段階の
細胞変化を捉えられる可能性がわかりまし
た
そこで次は
卵巣癌についての解析を行いました
実は
卵巣外には大きく分けて4種類のガンが
ございます
合計4500個の細胞について
願書が区別できるのかということを検証し
てみるとこちらも95.2%という制度が
得られました
ちなみにこの4種類を通常のデジタル画像
によって識別しようとした研究では
78.2%という制度しか得られており
ませんでしたのでハイパースペクトル画像
によってデジタル画像を超える高精度な
識別が可能であることを示したと言えます
もちろん100%でない以上改善の余地は
ございますハイパースケジュールカメラが
監視も識別できる可能性がわかったという
ことが大きな発見だと考えています
そしてこれらの識別は
実は
細胞核のみを
運航情報で判断しています
細胞の核これは
遺伝子の変化が最初にマクロに現れてくる
部分でもあります
つまりハイパースクトルカメラがマクロな
遺伝進化を見られるのではないかという
ことを示唆していますこれは本当に画期的
なことです
遺伝変化は常に体内で起こっています
その影響で1日がん細胞は5000個近く
生成されているとも言われていますが
原因とされる電子変化がどのようにがんに
つながるかということは
十分に解明されていません
遺伝変化が起こったからといって
必ず癌になるというわけではないんです
私はハイパースペクトカメラによって
遺伝子変化と
癌細胞の関係これをより明確にすることが
できがんの原因究明に一歩近づくのでは
ないかと考えています
実際に大腸がんの検体をハイパー
スペクトルカメラによって撮影し大腸がん
の細胞核の色合いから
ケーラス遺伝子という特有の遺伝子の発言
の有無を予測したところ最大77%の予測
精度が得られました
今後もさらにこうした研究を進めていく
予定です
私はハイパースペシャルカメラにより
疾患ごとの色を見分けていくそして
細胞に不足している光波長を識別し
適切な
光線治療に向かせるのではないかと思って
います
光で診断し
治療するという
光による医療改革が起きてくることを期待
しています
私は高校生の時
物理学に魅了されました
それはなぜかというと
物理学はそれまで常識とされていた世界を
世界観それを
壊して人々に夢を与えてくれるからです
コペルニクスケプラ
ガリレオといった方々はそれまでの地球
中心の考え方を
太陽中心に変えました
これによって人々は
実は地球のような惑星がたくさん存在する
のではないかと信じるようになりました
このように物理学は人々に夢と希望を与え
てくれます
私はハイパースティックカメラは未知の
世界への扉を開く一つの影になると思って
います
すでに分かっている
研究され尽くしていると思われたこの色の
世界にまだまだ未知の世界が広がってい
ますこの人類水戸の地には
ノーベル賞級の発明発見もタイムカプセル
のような
過去から
未来に届けられたメッセージも
数多く存在します
私はこのゴーストたちに光を当て
世界をより
光に満ちたものへと変えていきたいと思っ
ています
科学は未知なるものへの挑戦です